Who are you under there what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better
world that's why he saved me
you can go to any timeline and the
universe might fight to save this one
what could be greater than a king
the hero
i just got goosebumps
if we don't stand up no one will
come with us
it's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
are you in
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my dc movie super bowl trailer video they
release footage for all the upcoming movies that
they're releasing this year black adam the batman
the flash movie aqua band 2 so there's a bunch of
new footage for everything we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel i'll
be doing super bowl trailer videos for
all the marvel trailers tomorrow there's a lord of
the rings trailer coming too be sure to subscribe
to be the first to watch those it is going to
be crazy this weekend in the best possible way
i'm sure there's also some cool football stuff
that's going to be happening too we secretly
know why you're all really watching the super
bowl because of all the trailers i'll start
with the black adam trailer footage first then
i'll talk about the stuff from the other movies
but the black adam trailer gives us our first
full look at the brand new dceu justice society
in the movie in present day after black adam is
released from his magical prison where the wizard
shazam put him for 5000 years the justice society
of the dceu has been in shambles there was one in
the distant past of the dceu but i believe
the idea is that some of the original roster
of older superheroes died at some point and
only doctor fate and hawkman are left and in
the present they're going to form a new justice
society roster with cyclone and adam smasher who
you see both in their plane clothes and also in
their costumes and even though black adam was
featured heavily during the justice society comics
and in the trailer doctor fate is asking him
please join us in helping save the world black
adam isn't going to become a member of the dceu
justice society he's not a team player that's just
not something he would do in the movie it's more
of a temporary alliance after which he would go
back to kondok to rule over it permanently like he
does in the comics he spends the vast majority of
his time in kondok actually being their main ruler
actively on a daily basis and obviously at the end
of the movie they'll set up shazam vs black adam
crossover in their next movies like after shazam
2 more like shazamly versus black adam that big
crossover won't actually be happening till like
shazam 3 or black adam 2 not till after both of
their next movies however they want to handle that
like what they'll actually call it black adam 2
might actually wind up being black adam versus
henry cavill superman if the rock has his way
we'll see about that the brand new footage starts
with black adam in his full cape from the comics
like his cloak is on getting ready to wreck some
military helicopters in conduct all the scenes in
the trailer here where he's wearing his full cloak
seem like they're right after he comes out of that
magical prison as he's learning what's happened
to the world of the past 5000 years like learning
about all this modern technology weaponry and
then destroying them like they're bugs like oh
you have all these guns and missiles and bombs and
they don't even leave a scratch on him imagine him
soaking all this damage like superman like he's
so op missiles would just tickle him a little bit
and they'll just use scenes like this early on
to show you how powerful he is and how he has no
problem killing people he's way more powerful
than shazam mostly because of the way shazam
shares his power with the shazamly black adam
does not share his power with anyone so he's
operating at a hundred percent of his potential
all the time whereas shazam is only ever at a
fractional amount of his potential the only reason
why the shazamly ever has a chance against black
adam is when they all coordinate their attacks
together but usually they're not all together
all fighting him at the same time when he's inside
these ruins here talking to hawkman this is inside
the ruins where they found him you notice hawkman
is in his full comic book armor there's a couple
scenes with him where he unfurls his wings you see
his spaceship black adam says his son dreamt of a
better world and that's why he saved him you see
a flashback scene of him right before he became
black adam when he was still asleep and it seems
like they're beating him or they're getting ready
to kill him and i believe what he means when he
says his son saved him is that his son sacrificed
his life to save him from these slave masters in
ancient conduct and black adam was forced to watch
them kill his son his wife died too so something
similar may have happened to his wife and that's
why he's so hardcore why he swears revenge and
uses the power of shazam when he got it although
in the back story that we got in the first shazam
movie about what happened in ancient conduct what
happened to the original group of wizards in the
rock of eternity is actually the seven deadly
sins that tricked black adam into releasing them
as a way to get revenge for the death of his son
and wife and then the seven deadly sins are the
ones that kill everyone in conduct in the other
wizards in the rock of eternity all except for the
wizard shazam that's how they're making black adam
more sympathetic as an anti-hero by saying
he was manipulated by the seven deadly sins
so all these deaths aren't totally his fault and
the people that he did kill because he did kill a
lot of people were really really bad people like
i said the spaceship here you see flying through
the arctic or somewhere near conduct in these
mountains in this part of the world is hawkman
ship there are thanegarian symbols all over it
so maybe we'll get some flashbacks to thanogar
when they're doing hawkbands origin story in the
movie i don't know how much of that we're gonna
get in this first movie the hawkman continuity in
the comics is a little bit confusing so we'll see
which version of hawkman's origin story they're
going within the dc eu and the rock did say that
at one point they were going to have hawkgirl in
the movie but he implied they had to cut her out
because some other upcoming dc movie is going
to be using her they didn't say which one but
we'll see a version of hawkgirl at some point the
thana guardians are powerful aliens that wield nth
metal which is sort of like the dceu version of
vibranium an ultra rare ultra powerful ore that
very few people outside of the thanegarians have
access to all of his armor his ship his technology
is based on nth metal in the trailer footage they
show you black adam using his magical lightning to
destroy a bunch of stuff for example hawkman's
armor could soak some of that magical lightning
this is cyclone on their ship in her costume we
don't see her using her powers in the trailer
but they are exactly what you think they are she
creates cyclones pretty simple there is footage of
her in adam smasher in what looks like the jsa
mansion where doctor fate probably lives this
chair seems like nth metal and you can see some
precious artifacts behind him here if you've ever
watched any young justice episodes doctor fate
is also the keeper of the tower of fate which is
like his secret magical lair where he lives and
keeps all his most dangerous magical artifacts
it's a little bit like the rock of eternity and
because they already have the rock of eternity
in the shazam black adam cannon i don't know if
they're going to actually do the house of fate
so i think this is just meant to be the jsa
mansion everyone's costumes look pretty solid
doctor fate hawkman adam smasher cyclone black
adam in fact they just upgraded all the shazamly
costumes for shazam 2 to make them more hardcore
and look similar to the black adam costume
the only difference in the rox black adam costume
is that he does not wear padding underneath his
costume 100 original there because adam smasher is
so young i'm also wondering if he's going to wind
up being the son of the previous adam smasher his
abilities look like they're powered by his belt
here his costume looks kind of old-timey like
it was designed by the original atom smasher on
the original version of the jsa at some point
in the dc eu history they did do a version of
adam smasher in the flash season 2 that you
may remember he was a little bit different
he was played by edge from wwe but it was actually
pretty solid at the time there are a couple other
scenes of black adam busting out of his tomb here
with all these carvings of people around him but
because the movie's coming out this summer we'll
probably get a bigger trailer when they release
the batman movie in march and speaking of which
next up there isn't a ton of brand new batman
footage in this so i'm just gonna skip over that
there was a separate batman super bowl trailer
that they released so i will do a video for that
in the next couple of days as i get through all
the different super bowl trailers that are coming
this weekend the new flash movie trailer is pretty
brief it's mostly just hyping up some of the new
aspects of the upgraded flash suit notice that
it's got retractable visors in his eyepieces like
he lowers them when he runs the voiceover from
michael keaton's batman is also the same one from
the last trailer so not a ton of brand new footage
here the new aquaman 2 lost kingdom footage is of
him in that new stealth suit that's why it looks
so dark it's just a cell suit there's also a new
scene of him in the old suit sitting on the throne
of atlantis not a ton of brand new footage i've
already done a full breakdown video of the bigger
aquaman 2 trailer they released last year so i'll
add a link for that in the description below the
lost kingdom that they reference in the title of
the movie is the lost seventh kingdom of atlantis
originally atlantis was a nation made up of seven
different kingdoms that broke apart when it sank
based on the other trailer footage the lost
kingdom seems like it's either underneath the
arctic in the north or underneath antarctica in
the south the movie is going to be a big aquaman
aurum team-up movie black manta will be one
of the main villains maybe not the actual main
villain but definitely one of the main villains
but now they're playing ocean master as more of
an anti-hero if you spotted any other big easter
eggs in the trailer footage for all the different
movies that i didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments my marvel super
bowl trailer videos will start posting tomorrow
my lord of the rings trailer will probably post
on monday i will put links for all those videos
in the description as i start posting them too
be sure to enable alerts for my channel to be
the first to watch those everyone click here for
my new mandalorian season 3 video and click
here for my marvel moon night trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!